[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio y las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo lo que estaba destinado a
hacer el primer debate presidencial se
convirtió en una batalla campal como
nunca había sucedido en un evento de
este tipo en eeuu muy al estilo
preferido por el presidente de donald
trump tan pronto como joe biden el
presidente se vieron cara a cara hubo
interrupciones insultos y acusaciones en
su mayoría sin fundamento constantemente
alimentadas por el mandatario que
interrumpía a su oponente algo que éste
también empezó a hacer y no respeto al
moderador ni las reglas previamente
pactadas para el debate en france 24
analizamos algunas de las afirmaciones
más polémicas y verificamos su veracidad
empezamos en un caótico y acalorado
debate de donald trump y joe biden se
enfrentaron cara a cara por primera vez
durante más de 90 minutos en una
situación que hasta el moderador chris
wallace se les salió de las manos por lo
que fue duramente criticado las falsas
acusaciones que donald trump lanzó en
2016 contra su entonces rival hillary
clinton y las muchas otras afirmaciones
abiertamente falsas que lo han
caracterizado pusieron en alerta a los
de comunicación
cada una de las afirmaciones del
presidente de donald trump y de su
ponente joe biden fueron sometidas a una
minuciosa verificación ofac checking
aunque las más numerosas fueron las de
donald trump como ya es habitual bailén
también incurrió en ellas
trump fue confrontado por las recientes
revelaciones que indican que no pagó
impuestos en una década
y dirá cuánto pagó en impuestos
federales en 2016 y 2017 en ana isabel
millones de dólares pagó millones de
dólares millones de dólares y podrá ver
lo que trump asegura que pagó millones
de dólares es una afirmación
cuestionable aunque las finanzas de
trump han sido un enigma un reporte del
new york times indicó que el mandatario
no pagó impuestos sobre la renta en 10
de los últimos 15 años debido a que
reportó millonarias pérdidas
una práctica contable común entre los
millonarios estadounidenses para reducir
sus impuestos el diario mencionó que en
2016 el mandatario solo pagó 750 dólares
lo mismo que en 2017
bailén dijo que durante su periodo como
vicepresidente fue el responsable de
sacar al país de una recesión que le fue
heredada al gobierno de barack obama y
que trump ha echado a perder este
trabajo escuchemos william le dejamos
una economía en auge y él causó las
recesiones el new york times calificó
estas afirmaciones como falsas de
acuerdo con el diario el crecimiento
económico de estados unidos se aceleró
con donald trump es decir pasó del 1.6
por ciento en 2016 a 2.3 por ciento en
2019 según el departamento de trabajo
sombras y vio en 2017 una tasa de
desempleo de l 4.7 por ciento y antes de
la pandemia el porcentaje de desocupados
había bajado al 3.5 por ciento su nivel
más bajo en casi medio siglo el 'new
york times' añadió que no hay evidencia
de que haya causado la recesión ya que
todos los principales países ricos del
mundo han experimentado una fuerte
contracción económica a medida que
lidian con sus brotes de kobe 19 baiden
criticó el pésimo manejo que trump le
dio a la pandemia el presidente siempre
insistió en que el virus desaparecería
pero dos días después del debate yo
probablemente salvaremos
no son buenas y luego cambió de opinión
según politifact esta información es
engañosa el portal rescata una
entrevista del doctor anthony fauci
principal asesor médico de la casa
blanca en marzo de este año aclarando
que lo que falta en realidad dijo fue
que en ese momento en eeuu la gente no
debería andar con máscaras esto debido a
que todavía la situación no era tan
grave como en asia
desde que inició la carrera por la casa
blanca hunter bailén el hijo de joe
biden ha sido la comidilla preferida de
los republicanos el presidente volvió a
vincularlo en casos de corrupción con
empresas extranjeras
así como tu almuerzo yo no es de
extrañar que tu hijo entre y saque miles
de millones de dólares
whittaker rangers de acuerdo con la
empresa bloomberg las acusaciones
relacionadas con china carecen de
evidencia en su portal recopila que en
2017 hunter baiden invirtió 420 mil
dólares en un fondo de inversión
vinculado al gobierno chino lo que le
otorgaba una participación del 10 por
ciento también añade que su abogado
mencionó que hunter nunca recibió
beneficios económicos por ello en 2014
dicha empresa se había fijado como
objetivo recaudar 1.500 millones de
dólares pero lo que trump ha
interpretado es que china le dio esa
cantidad de dinero a hunter bailén para
poder influir en su padre joe by the
ground se ha negado a comprometerse a
respetar los resultados de las
elecciones del 3 de noviembre
constantemente y sin ningún fundamento
el presidente ha sembrado dudas sobre la
integridad del voto
y la agencia associated press dijo que
trump está exagerando en sus amenazas en
su página web agregó que según dijo el
director del fbi christopher reid no se
ha visto históricamente en ningún tipo
de esfuerzo coordinado de fraude
electoral nacional importante ya sea por
correo o de otro modo fue donald trump
quien trajo una mayor cantidad de
afirmaciones sin fundamento en su
mayoría son teorías que el presidente ya
había mencionado antes pero continúa
haciéndolas a pesar de que ya han sido
desmentidas este caótico encuentro
generó un acalorado debate en eeuu donde
se le califica como el peor de la
historia y muchos analistas han llamado
a cancelar los tres que faltan si no hay
un cambio en las reglas la comisión de
debates presidenciales de eeuu informó
que habrá modificaciones en el formato
de los próximos debates para garantizar
una discusión más ordenada queda por
verse cómo será el próximo con el ya
predecible donald trump
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir esta otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www puntos
france24 puntocom
[Música]